we will look at multiplication
multiplication at its geometric meeting
that's what makes sense of why we have
polar form in the first place okay but
once you understand like this vector
idea that you can think of complex
numbers as like a go here go there this
unlocks all kinds of really helpful
things okay before I get to this just
look at that diagram we had before which
had written three rows I 3 on 2 2 plus
that diagram okay
ask you a quick question I could ask you
to do this of any other numbers but if
I've got Zed there as root 3 plus I okay
can you tell me where is said ba the
conjugate is added where is it in
relation to Zed this is my said ok so
one second so I can actually just write
out what the complex conjugate is right
3 3 plus I is video number so root 3
minus I will be the conjugate now the
root 3 means are the same horizontal
position but the - I mean I'm not going
to go up that far we go down so here and
you may want to add this it if you are
luminous based on there if that's as it
is and ZEB bar is down here now this is
really useful to me because it points
out that if I know what Z is right if it
has some modulus and some argument tell
me what's the relationship between the
moduli of Zed and zipa what's the
relationship they are the same right if
I look I'm facing that way facing that
way but the distance is still ah but the
able it has changed I am about facing in
the same direction anymore
right instead of going up that angle
I've gone down that angle right so I
could say that this is going to be cos
all
okay does that make sense so this is a
really useful property and we're going
to use it a lot more in the future but I
just want you to notice where cultural
okay right now to finish off I want to
push on this vector idea a little more
and do some geometry with you because
this is one of the cool things about
complex numbers that we used to thinking
of arithmetic and geometry as two
completely separate things right is that
this is the one where I have to do long
division and this is the one we're after
new code words bruiser they have nothing
to do with each other
they're complex numbers shattered that
you know that separation and show you
they're really the same thing I have got
a couple of planes here I get diagram
and I've got these two numbers that I'm
interested in understanding their
relationship
so there's head there's W now quick
question for you is the first one what's
the sum of these two complex numbers
it's the same we add the real parts and
then you add the imaginary parts worth
pointing out by the way polar form super
useful for multiplying complex numbers
right but kind of a bit of a pain if all
you want to do is add them right so do
you see how different forms leave you in
different directions depending on what
you want to do okay great so examples W
this purpose five like where is that
point out diagram where physically is it
it's all the way up here right so I've
got one two three four five and that's
also five so I'm gonna put that okay now
at the moment this just looks like a
random set of three points okay but
using the our understanding of vectors
unlocks what is happening okay
so need another Colleen I'm gonna draw
in the vectors pizzetta Tommy he's said
that's that vector and he is w is that
vector okay yeah don't draw this but
like when you think on the number line
right if I said to you 2 plus 3 is 0 is
2 history to possibly of course gets you
to 5 right that's the same as doing the
vector plus 2 and then after that the
Victor +3 do you agree with that it's
like one vector after another it's like
just chucking the other in a cave what's
exactly what zip plus W is do you see
that it's like here's the Z vector if
you do Z and then you do the W vector
after that look at this W vector and
look at its relation to this one right
it's the same vector right Z plus W
right it's just stringing the vectors
together and of course we know addition
is commutative what does that mean again
commutated commutativity it means that
you can add numbers and you can add them
in any order you like and you'll still
get the same number 2 plus 3 is 3 plus 2
and then what's w w % their safety
geometrically wife feet is said first
then you add W that's where you go oh if
you do W first and then you add said
it's still the same thing what you're
getting here this is actually called the
parallelogram law right you have
constructed a parallelogram and the
sides of the parallelogram are these
vectors n Adame
okay and this is really cool these are
lots of whole world point for instance I
asked you for z+ dubbing what's um
what's it - them just look at it look at
the numbers looks like it's gonna be
minus 3 plus I okay now again I'm you'll
need more quadrants this time right
that's wise N&W are Z minus W is going
to be minus 3 1 2 3 plus I he's so why
is that how does that I'll understand
your vectors he is Z how does that
understand your vectors help
okay so you can see I mean we hardly
even think about this right but 2 2-3
right is also a summer vectors that from
the Sun is 2 plus what what number am i
adding 2 to negative 3 right but we know
the relationship between 3 and negative
3 they're just facing in opposite
directions right and it's the same with
this you're adding two vectors together
and I know where negative W is it's a
minus 4 - 1 2 3 4 - 2 1 - that's
negative W over there
right can you see the connection look
Zed - W right you see again it's just
another parallelogram with someone
waiting life sorry about that
do you see what's going on so I've got
parallelograms everywhere how about say
W - ed don't even do the computation
tell me where it's gonna go you go W
first like that and then - mbeans go
down that way right so just look at this
visually it should be something like
this yeah like that do you see that
again you get another parallelogram like
that and now you can compute it and tell
me that I'm right W minus Z is going to
me what's the real part 3 and that's
gonna be - I isn't it 3 or not my scale
was a bit off but you get the idea
right you see what's happening okay so
you don't even need to think of that
these numerically you can think about
these as geometric objects that are just
interacting with each other okay now
because this opens up a whole new
geometric world right I'm dealing with
numbers this is not coming to oratory
it's co-eds numbers complex numbers are
geometry and that's what we're gonna
focus on next week